what do a goldfish driving a robot on
land a rat cruising around in a lab and
a california girl trekking around in the
snow have in common we're all doing
things that don't come naturally to us
and still we figured out how to succeed
in unfamiliar situations and
environments how
it has to do with what's up here and the
fact that we're not hard-headed quite
the opposite actually
mental flexibility is critical to all
brains and really to our survival but
before we get into the wonderful world
of brains neuroplasticity and learning
let's set indoors because it's freezing
out here
so now that we're settled in let's start
with the goldfish
what you're seeing here is it's robo
ride down the side of a street but
before the fish was let loose it had to
learn to drive indoors as part of a
recent experiment to test whether fish
actually had the brain power to learn to
drive a vehicle and that answer was a
resounding yes so a goldfish can drive
why does that even matter adaptation to
new environment and
new ways of advancing in space this is
very important for all animals not just
for fish but also for us that's roman
seguin the neuroscientists who train the
fish to drive the brain's plasticity or
flexibility to adapt is critical for our
survival it's what allows us to come up
with creative solutions to hard problems
like finding friends or food or avoiding
threats like predators and the extreme
cold by studying animals scientists can
get insights into how different brains
react to new challenges and what their
limits might be that's important in two
ways for understanding the evolution of
brains generally and for understanding
what goes wrong when brains malfunction
the goldfish and rodents experiment had
to learn to steer a robotic vehicle
towards a pink target in a terrestrial
environment ronan compared the
experience of his fish to humans in
outer space where humans have to learn
to move in zero gravity sometimes inside
cumbersome spacesuits
his goldfish had to figure out their
position in the tank controlled the way
the vehicle moved it's not unlike when
we learn to ride a bike or drive a car
we know that this is actually a very
complex motor task and the fish didn't
just manage they adapted and thrived
they got so good that about a dozen
driving sessions in they were getting
full lunch from this experiment
each time the fish hit their pink target
they got a bit of fish food remember
that word because we're going to come
back to it later even when the
researchers moved the target or added
decoys the fish still made their way to
the food it's not an accidental just
bumping into the target due to some
random motion over time their path to
lunch became more direct they really
knew where they were going this fish
driving experiment and another test i'm
about to tell you in just a sec are
important for two reasons first animals
are smart maybe smarter than we give
them credit for in some ways they're
kind of super achievers that's kelly
lambert a neuroscientist who studies
stress anxiety and resilience but in her
experiments rats rather than fish are
the stars the fact that animal brains
are capable of some pretty complex
behaviors gives researchers like kelly
more confidence that we can learn
something about ourselves by studying
other animals that's important because
researchers often use animal brains as
proxies for ours so knowing how far they
can be challenged is important for
improving the basic research that guides
clinical development it's still not
perfect because rats are not little
humans and we're not big brats
but it's a starting point i promised you
a second insight so here it is
motivation and reward is important for
learning and adapting for ronan's
goldfish it was fish food and in kelly's
lab our rats love fruit i don't know if
that's a good endorsement for fruit loop
cereal but
they'll work for that incidentally fruit
loops maker kellogg's did not respond to
a request for comment over the course of
months her team coaxed the rats to take
up driving by rewarding them with sugary
cereal in the process her team noticed
an interesting difference between the
two sets of rats they were working with
one group lived in standard cages the
other rats had bigger cages with toys
and other rats to play with pura vida
edition the animals in the enriched
environment learned faster meaning it
took them fewer sessions to go from the
start line to the finish line where they
were rewarded with more food loops we
see something similar in humans we know
that having access to education
resources and nice living environment
when we're kids that all sets us up for
success later in life as for the rats
the researchers also noticed another
interesting difference once the rats
were familiarized with their ride kelly
noticed that the privileged rats grow
further even without the fruit loop
stimulus
something about their brains that were
different that allowed kelly doesn't
know what the difference was
anatomically but she wants to take a
look at how the connections between
brain cells change as rats learn to
drive neurons are so wonderful like
they're trees with roots and connections
so
those existing neurons can
be plugged into more circuits the
strengthening of neural connections and
the sprouting of new ones is fundamental
for brain plasticity even without
knowing these details it's clear that
something about the rats prior
experience shaped their perception of
reward and made them either less or more
prone to explore
neuroscientists know that novelty can be
rewarding too so maybe the rats in the
fancy cages were more attuned to that
and their brains were already primed to
experiment and adapt so what does this
mean for us when we look closer at the
fish and the rats driving they're really
showing us neuroscience in action
they're evidence that our brains are
incredibly flexible and that our
experience has the power to shape us and
how we function in the world they also
show us that rewards motivate us to try
new things and that experimenting can
help prepare us for the unexpected
helping to increase our chances for
survival those are some pretty profound
lessons from viral videos that at first
glance look like party tricks as you can
probably tell i love brains so if you
have neuroscience related questions
please leave them in the comments and
while you're at it hit subscribe if
you're interested in human drivers check
out our mobility channel thanks for
watching e gracias
the strength oh my god i broke it
you